quick favor please be on the lookout for  an item that was lost in the theater  earlier today it looks like this it's a  big metal glove with some colorful  stones in it sits controls I guess time  and space and it wields I'm told  unthinkable powers anyway if you happen  to see fan OSes Infinity Gauntlet please  return it to one of the ushers that  would be terrific Conan I think I might  know what happened to Thanos Infinity  Gauntlet you you've seen it something  like that I can't find my sweatshirt do  we have a lost-and-found  over there Thanks there you are I can  literally do any long time next question  which late-night talk show host  introduced the world to wiki bear and  FedEx Pope Pat Sajak Conan  all [ __ ] too easy I'll show you easy  moving on what famous  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  let me help you I'm sorry your kid  you're all-powerful now  [Applause]  yeah so so a little girl has it  you